un service public accessible à tous
c'est la promesse de la nouvelle maison
France service à Maurepas inauguré en
présence du ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique Stanislas Guerini ce nouveau
réseau compte désormais très structure
dans les Yvelines l'objectif est d'aider
les habitants dans leur démarche
administratives ce qui est très
important en tout cas moi ce que je veux
dire c'est d'apporter un service
physique c'est ce qu'attendent nos
concitoyens faut qu'on continue à à
numériser à simplifier des démarches je
crois que les Français ils veulent avoir
des voix et des visages en phase 2 et on
a des très bons exemples ici de nombreux
services sont disponibles un
accompagnement pour faire sa déclaration
de revenus sa recherche d'emploi ou
encore accéder à son compte ameli
ouverte en avril dernier cette maison
France service accueille une trentaine
d'usagers par semaine en six mois on a
quand même 64 74% des objectifs atteints
en termes d'usagers par rapport au
relais Marianne habituel donc ça veut
dire qu'on va certainement atteindre
1500 usagers d'ici la fin de l'année
donc c'est une une belle réussite les
trois agents France services de mots
repas proposent également un
accompagnement au numérique on a
proposition de borne sur le relais
Marianne soit en libre accès soit on se
propose d'accompagner les personnes pour
les guider dans leur démarche
et on organise aussi des ateliers pour
pouvoir être autonome sur le dans les
démarches est arrivé récemment sur mon
repas et la pub bénéficier de la maison
française pour connaître ses droits et
devenir autonome dans ses démarches pour
les enfants surtout pour s'inscrire au
Centre de Loisirs et pour les droits de
la CAF pour comment faire pour se
bénéficier fin juin 719 personnes
avaient déjà pu bénéficier de
l'accompagnement de la structure de mon
repas face à ce succès le gouvernement
proposera prochainement un
enrichissement du bouquet de service